[Music]
the walkers on the walking dead have
become an iconic
group of tv villains but they didn't get
there by doing anything they want on the
screen
here are the rules walkers have to
follow to keep their inherent
walkerness intact on the hit amc series
shortly after you die in the walking
dead's universe assuming your brains
remain intact
you rise as a soulless carcass and feast
upon the warm
wet flesh of the living but unlike
undead creatures from other
similar media walkers and walking dead
must drag themselves forward with an
exhausted vertical crawl
they can pick up a tiny bit of speed at
the sight of a possible meal but
under no circumstances can they run or
even really
jog if a walker propels themselves with
a velocity roughly equal to what zombies
pull off in zombieland then that walker
is moving
way too fast and hey that's just fine
walkers aren't frightening because of
their athletic prowess you never have to
worry about a single walker chasing you
down
even if that walker won multiple sprint
championships during their pre-walker
days
most of the time walkers only become a
threat once they've gathered in large
enough numbers to overwhelm a potential
victim or victims
or in the occasional instance in which
they successfully sneak up on their prey
both of those things are definitely
frequent enough to make walkers a
major threat even if they aren't going
to be chasing anyone down
anytime soon walkers are not effective
or
efficient predators they're not fast
strong
smart or well equipped with any
offensive tools except the rotting teeth
they have no capacity for cutting or any
skill with long-term planning
most of them aren't even aesthetically
pleasing in a manner that might be
useful for luring victims into traps
their appearance is quite to the
contrary in fact most walkers are so
disgusting to behold
they make you want to run screaming in
the opposite direction
these things ain't sick they're not
people they're dead
too bad for the walkers but these
circumstances work out splendidly for
those of us here in the real world
hordes of grotesque and gruesome undead
are visually distinctive in a way that
sticks with the viewer long after the tv
has been shut off
we tune into programs like the walking
dead because we want to see the menacing
hordes of the undead and we want to see
them
hideously disfigured in the world of the
walking dead walkers
are terrifying and in a world where a
zombie apocalypse hasn't happened yet
that's exactly what we want walkers
possess several qualities that inhibit
their people-eating abilities while
enhancing their entertainment value
for example in most cases you can hear
them coming from long distances off
due to their apparently compulsive need
to make weird
barfing noises sometimes walkers make
very loud barfing noises and sometimes
they lower the volume of their
barfing noises to a very quiet level but
one truth remains
regardless walkers will make
uncomfortable
guttural noises no matter the situation
they practically never stop making these
noises even though they don't seem to
serve
any purpose for them in fact it gives
away their location
and offers potential human meals plenty
of time to run away
however it does add ominous ambiance and
the walking dead wouldn't quite be
itself without it
walkers can't talk scream or sing in
their hideous version of the afterlife
but they don't need to
because those horrible hissing moans of
theirs haunt
our dreams look if you don't
absolutely love completely uncooked
literally fresh off the bone human meat
then you've got no business being a
walker
it's basically their whole deal walkers
lead boring
bland lives if we're being honest they
indefinitely roam about with no purpose
or direction
until their limited abilities of
detection pick up on one of the
dwindling
number of humans who have not already
been converted into walkers
they only really want one thing and it's
the thing that keeps the danger of the
show going
the flesh of the living the gang of
sympathetic survivors on the walking
dead
often find themselves in life or death
conflicts with groups of malignant
fellow humans
while these plots unfold walkers are
relegated to the background
sometimes in a quite literal sense some
critics don't like this but unless you
just want the walkers to eat people over
and over and over
it's the way it has to be if the walkers
were the only villains on the show it
would just be a constant buffet of human
meat
feasting on human flesh is literally the
whole gig for a walker
this is basically the only rule that
applies to both walkers
and humans if your brain dies you die
no exceptions it doesn't matter whether
you get shot in the face or head
or whether someone pierces your grey
matter with a blade or pointed object
a swift blow of blunt force could also
do the trick as long as it punctures the
protective bone layer and squashes the
wrinkled ball of goo within
in any of these cases that's the end of
the story for you
you can no longer claim the status of
undead you're just well
dead the good news for walkers about
this rule though is that they can
survive virtually
anything up to this point including
having their head flat out removed from
their body
take a walker apart any way you like as
long as they still have a brain working
in their head
they'll just watch you do it which might
be all the more reason to kill the brain
and get it over with
it's simple strategy any walker hoping
to sink their diseased
blunted teeth into a still living
screaming person
needs to find themselves a crew a single
walker might get lucky and stumble
upon an injured human or a very stupid
child every now and again
but most of the time a walker on their
own is basically just a sitting duck for
the next human survivor with a weapon
sticking with a large group doesn't mean
a walker
definitely won't get their brains bashed
in at some point but hanging with a
crowd demonstrably increases their
chances of finding a person
and actually getting a meal out of the
deal people who see a herd of walkers
get scared
run away in a random direction and
sometimes find their way into a dead end
where walkers can descend upon them if
you're a walker doing the lone wolf
thing though you're just as likely to
end up with a machete through your head
so stick with your friends as far as
options for the afterlife go
walker hood is kind of boring you
stumble around looking for fresh meat
and if you find it attempt to shove it
in your face until there's no more meat
apart from that you're just killing time
until someone comes along and
caves in your skull you told me to
handle them easily
this is easy yeah it's easier to
something
being a walker certainly limits your
options but at least it's easy and
low pressure among walkers there's no
hierarchy walkers don't have
walker bosses who tell them what to do
walkers don't get a reward for eating
somebody they just
immediately resume looking for a new
person to eat so whether they eat one
person in a week or 12
it doesn't make any difference it
doesn't matter if you're a successful
walker or
a failure as a walker walkers don't
really compete with each other in fact
if it wasn't for the inevitable violent
demise
total loss of cognitive function and
endless craving for flesh
being a walker would be a pretty relaxed
gig they're comfortable living in the
moment
the awful bloody post-apocalyptic moment
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one